now for a long time I've been a
proponent of saying that it doesn't
matter what your language is or what
your platform is if you follow the
memory you'll find performance problems
and believe it or not JavaScript and
html5 is no different that's why I want
to point you at this final option down
here on your profiles tab called record
heap allocations now what this is going
to do this is actually going to make a
log of all of the allocations that occur
while your web application is running so
I'm going to turn this on and play
through the game a little bit so you can
see how the memory is reacting to the
gameplay
and of course with that one alien
destroyed I've now saved the universe
now sizing up this window a little bit
actually gives us a lot of information
about what was allocated during that
small time playing so first off you can
see that we have the types of objects
that were allocated in this column the
distance is not necessarily as important
as you would need it to be right now so
let's ignore that most important is
actually the shallow size metric which
actually shows you the number of bytes
allocated to this type of objects you
can see here that the compiled code
object is roughly taking about two
megabytes or twenty-eight percent of our
overall frame heap expanding compiled
code actually gives us locations in
executable memory that tells us what
type of data is being allocated now this
is code information so it's actually not
going to be that important to you unless
you're doing a lot of script injection
now probably a lot more useful to you is
actually going to be a little bit lower
in the stack this object header you see
here this is actually going to list all
of the class types or object definitions
that have been created during our little
playback expanding this actually gives
us a bunch of pointers into the memory
heap clicking on one shows us the
retaining tree for the object so if we
bring this up a little bit we can see
that there was a module that was called
from IG you can see that there was a lot
of little global functions that kind of
came into play so clicking through this
list a little bit more we can find
probably some interesting data so here
you can see that this one was actually
an allocation of a collision map object
so somewhere while these objects were
falling or debris was occurring the
collision map was called and you can see
a lot of the object information listed
here